BREWING IN THE GAME.
WE'RE UNDERWAY, SHOT,
SCORES! PASSOT, THAT ONE WENT O
AND HE COULDN'T TAP IT IN ON
JEKS.POINT, JONES, A
SHOT, FRONT TOCROSS THE
CREASE.
FOUND TKACHUK, BUT COULDN'T FIRE
IT.
STUTZLE WALKING IN, FIRES, SCOR!
UNBELIEVABLE SHIFT FOR CHABOT.
AND YOU GOAT A REAL SENSE AS TO.
NOFRONT, THEY
SCORE!
THE PLAY MAKER TO THE CAPTAIN,
AND JOHATHAN TOEWS CUTS GETS
THERE.
MUCH QUICKER START TO THE IT.
>> Mike: HAGEL, SENDS IT FOR
KANE, KANE, IN FRONT, RIGHT
THROUGH THE  MAN,
AND TOEWS SCORES
NEUTRAL ICE WITH A BULLET PASS.
KANE DOES SUCH A GOOD JOB FOR A
SMALLER GUY, SCORES!
IT'S BURIES IT,
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE] YOU THIO
BIG AND STRONG, HE'S GOING TO
TAKE REPLY, IT'S LAFFERTY!
AND
ICE, SHOOTS BACK AGAINST THE
GRAIN AND BEATS FORSBERG ON THE
BLOCKER
>> Sam: NOT BAD FOR A GUY WHO
WAS NOT IN THE AS THE POINT.
PUTS IT ON
STICK, BUT FOR NOW,
AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
THEY MAY WANT TO HAVE A LOOK AT
KANE LOOKING FOR STROME AGAIN,
STROME IN  A RUSH FROM
NORRIS.
JOSH NORRIS,